So this leads us to the question, what is love? We touch on this briefly in the
lesson on language and thought, when Susan described what are emotional
feelings returned. Remember she was trying to tell Sofia that she was just
anxious or nervous about flying, when in fact Sophia's stomach was bothering
her and she was becoming physically sick. And in that lesson Susan asked what
is love and how do we describe it? One psychologist by the name of Sternberg,
developed the triangular theory of love. He had an idea that love was composed
of three components. They are intimacy, passion, and commitment. And various
combinations of these three components explain all forms of human love. So let's
take a closer look at these in a little more detail. Intimacy refers to feeling
close, connected, and bonded in your loving relationships. Next we have
passion. Passion refers to the drive that leads to physical attraction,
romance, and, sexual experiences. And this is accompanied by the physiological
changes in arousal. And finally, we have commitment. With commitment we're
talking about both a decision to love someone, and the decision to commit to
love for the long-term. So for different types of love, these three different
components are present, but they're present in different amounts. For example,
with romantic love, we see high levels of intimacy, and passion, but low levels
of commitment. And here we see companionate love. Which are high levels of
intimacy and commitment, but low levels of passion. And here we see fatuous
love, where there's high levels of commitment and passion but low levels of
intimacy. Now if you were to just have passion and no intimacy or commitment,
you'd see something like lust or infatuation. And if you just had intimacy but
no commitment or passion, It would just be liking someone, and if you just have
commitment, but no intimacy, and no passion, this would be empty love. Now if
all of these types of love were present in equal proportion, Sternberg would
call this consummate love. So, as I said that any given relationship can have a
combination of these three components. Some of your life-long friends you're
going to feel commitment with, and intimacy. But not passion. Or your siblings
and family members would be a mixture of intimacy and commitment. Whereas your
romantic partners would be intimacy and passion. And for those who have all
three in the same person, this would be a life-long partner. For example, a
husband or wife or life partner.